alright knurled Malaysian authorities
who claimed in all seriousness that the
earthquake near Mount Kinabalu was
caused by tourists taking nude photos on
the mountain must be told they're being
ridiculous ask anyone here in modern
America natural disaster - not caused by
tourists and nude photos they're caused
by abortion and gay marriage here all
the geniuses who just announced Apple
music the new killer app that features
professional humans instead of machines
constructing real-time playlists have to
be congratulated for inventing radio
new rule of Disneyland has to make a
rule not to use selfie sticks on the
rollercoasters then the magic of this
kingdom is that people this stupid got
this or maybe they need even more signs
like mermaid can breathe underwater but
not you
large duck and sailor suit not real duck
do not eat
Nero from now on all religions must
perform this ritual I don't know what it
is this guy could be getting baptized he
could be getting punked who cares
Genghis Khan is pimp slapping him with a
wet bra it's perfect especially for
people who think gay pride parades are
weird
thank you thank you sir
new rule if you get an efficient will
Mart that starts with you getting out of
your rascal scooter and and ends with
you telling your five-year-old your
white trash yeah and for now on these
videos
so now on these videos have to end like
one of those movies where everyone gets
a freeze-frame and a where are they now
start up TLC's here comes tubby punch
punch governor of Alaska and police
officer Orange County
you